economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros vamos a comenzar
hablando de china que le ganó la batalla
comercial a eeuu en la o ms como fuese
jonrón
santiago muy buenas noches pues mire la
organización mundial del comercio
determinó que los aranceles impuestos
por eeuu a china que dieron origen a la
guerra comercial son excesivos y violan
los derechos internacionales pues la
queja de beijing se originó en los
gravámenes impuestos en junio de 2018
por la casa blanca a exportaciones por
50 mil millones de dólares también los
que impuso tiempo después sobre otro
contingente de 200 mil millones de
dólares esta decisión no afecta a los
acuerdos a los que han llegado ambos
países para limar asperezas desde
comienzos de este año pero si
despertaron críticas en washington
escuchemos
tendremos que hacer algo con respecto a
la oms porque han dejado que china se
salga con la suya lo analizaremos pero
no soy un gran admirador de la oms y eso
se los puedo decir ahora mismo tal vez
nos hicieron un gran favor no
solucionadas a batalla en la o mc
daniela hablemos ahora del gobierno de
venezuela que le propuso a sus
acreedores un acuerdo para suspender los
pagos de su venta bueno la historia se
está en 2017 del país en crisis
suspendió los pagos a quienes habían
adquirido bonos públicos del estado así
como de sus empresas estatales en ese
momento intentó iniciar un proceso de
reestructuración como los que ya hemos
visto en argentina y en ecuador pero no
pudo hacerlo según el gobierno de
nicolás maduro por culpa de eeuu que les
prohíbe a los inversionistas negociar
con este país bajo la amenaza de que lo
sancionaría los pagos incumplidos suman
más de 10 mil millones de dólares y los
inversionistas pueden exigir sus
derechos por la vía legal pero santiago
tienen un tiempo límite que está a punto
de vencer escuchemos
la repubblica petróleos de venezuela y
la electricidad de caracas anuncian una
oferta condicional conjunta de
interrupción
de dichas entidades con el fin de
garantizar que los inversores no
resulten afectados por el ilegal
accionar de quienes detentan el poder en
los eeuu
daniela hay una cifra interesante ya se
sabe cuánto le ha costado la pandemia al
cove' 19 a la industria del turismo una
de las más afectadas y santiago tenemos
corte de cuentas al primer semestre de
este año es decir con casi 4 meses de
pandemia y parte de este tiempo con casi
todo el planeta confinado de acuerdo con
la organización internacional del
turismo en este periodo se perdieron 440
millones de llegadas internacionales de
turistas es decir bajó en un 65% con
respecto al mismo periodo del mes del
año pasado si hablamos en términos
económicos esto implicó pérdidas por 460
mil millones de dólares para calcular el
tamaño de esta crisis santiago mire el
organismo de naciones unidas dice que
esta pérdida es cinco veces más grande
que la que se tuvo en la recesión
económica mundial de 2009
muchos países afectados en su industria
turística daniele también la demanda
mundial de petróleo ha tenido retroceso
a niveles del 2013 pues con menos
aviones y automóviles circulando por el
mundo uno de los productos que menos se
ha consumido durante la pandemia es la
gasolina y en consecuencia el petróleo
las cifras que tengo son las siguientes
en todo 2019 al día se consumieron en
promedio 100 millones de barriles de
petróleo por día en todo el planeta para
este año los cálculos de la agencia
internacional de energía de eeuu apuntan
a que ese consumo va a bajar a 91 7
millones de barriles diarios o sea que
bajan en 8,3 millones o un 83 por ciento
respecto a 2019 uno de los grandes de la
industria que es la british petroleum va
más allá
santiago y dice que en 2050 todavía
vamos a estar viendo los efectos de la
pandemia en la demanda de crudo falta
entonces recuperación mucho tiempo
hablemos ahora de indicadores a ver si
están un poco más positivos sí señor
jornada positiva en wall street con las
tecnológicas todavía recuperándose de
las pérdidas de la semana pasada y
también con los ojos puestos en la
reunión de la reserva federal que
comenzó hoy las bolsas europeas subieron
en una jornada
relativamente tranquila en especial
londres y madrid que lo hicieron en más
del 1% y en américa latina la bolsa de
buenos aires cerró plana justo hoy que
el gobierno presentó al proyecto de
presupuesto para 2021 cifra para el
cierre los 400 millones de dólares que
invertirá la compañía en esa llegó para
tratar de producir sus bloques de
construcción usando materiales
sostenibles
esta empresa santiago utiliza unas
90.000 toneladas anuales de plástico a
base de aceite en sus productos quien no
jugó con un lego en su infancia el
católico también todo el tiempo muchas
gracias daniel as todo por el momento
aquí en france24 siga con nosotros